clarify you're not dating Katie Jamie
Foxx and Katie Holmes have called it
quits the notoriously private pair may
be throwing in the towel after six years
though a source tells ET not to rule out
a chance of a reconciliation for the
couple oh my god what Wow
adding the pair never had a typical
relationship and have always been very
independent Katie and Jamie kept their
romantic relationship mostly under wraps
the only real public appearance they
made together was in May at the Met Gala
however they didn't walk the carpet
together and only posed for photos
inside
over the years they were seen
vacationing and celebrating birthdays
together never officially confirming
their romantic relationship and I love
it according to our source the 40 year
old actress and the 51 year old actors
lives didn't revolve around each other
and only saw each other occasionally as
they both live in different cities quote
they are just both caught up in their
own families careers and obligations
that their relationship had to take a
backseat
although Katie and Jamie share great
chemistry our source says neither was
looking to uproot their lives or totally
merge lives the news comes just days
after Jamie set the rumor mill abuzz
when he was spotted holding hands with
singer celibate the Oscar winner and the
beautiful brunette were seen leaving
Bootsy bellows nightclub in West
Hollywood hand-in-hand apple juice but
another source tells et that babe is a
singer/songwriter Fox is helping and she
shared several pics with him on social
media thanking him for his mentorship I
can't be your friend right now could
this really be the end of homes and Fox
only time will tell it's exciting
[Music]